we heard there about Mark Carney saying
Net Zero is the great commercial
opportunity of our time well I think
that Net Zero is the wrong thing to be
aiming for in the next 20 years what we
need to be aiming for is zero because
what the net allows is the idea that
fine we're going to emit some carbon but
then somewhere else we're going to sort
of take some in and what that does is it
is Shifting currently now a huge amount
of focus and attention to people like Oh
Well what we'll do is we'll just work
out how to suckle the carbon out of the
atmosphere instead of focusing on not
emitting it in the first place and so I
think that's part of the problem if
you're going to have heavily regulated
capitalism how are you going to decide
on those regulations we know a huge
amount about the planet and we shouldn't
underestimate that but it's an
incredibly intricate system it is
already doing us enormous favors that we
don't necessarily appreciate and it's
already a very finely balanced system
[Music]
thank you